we are excited to bring you the second
game of the double head of the blue jays
pulling out another victory in a game
one and they have updated the standings
on the scoreboard
at fenway park on the monster and don't
look now but the toronto blue jays at
least at the moment are ahead of the new
york yankees as ross stripling makes his
blue jays debut
stripling's 30 years old you can see his
numbers from the dodgers he made seven
starts for la
and it didn't go so well stripling has
given up a home run in each of those
seven starts now the 2-2 is a fast ball
and that's popped up in the air out to
left field underneath it lourdes gorilla
jr is there and he makes the catch
verdugo retired
two down
the 2-2 pitch swing at a miss and
there's the fastball that devers
couldn't grab but he's got it dialed in
for a 1-2-3 first in boston in his blue
jay debut chris mazza yeah mazda
couldn't get out of the third inning
last time through a ton of pitches gets
another shot at it fastball and two
different types of sliders and here's
biggio
roped into right charging on that munoz
he'll make the play for round number one
richard with the base is empty here
and he'll pop that one into right
another play for munoz plenty of time to
get there backs up and he makes the
catch he had to make an adjustment
big smile he caught it two down dodges
it not win whoa i got to go back
two down here for teles
he's gonna smack that one into the gap
but there's jackie bradley moving on
over and it's a one two three start for
massa scoreless after an inning vasquez
to lead things off in the second
he'll stroke that one into center field
he drops down a base hit to get the red
sox underway in the second so one man
away for jackie bradley jr bunted toward
third and that's going to be a hit
beautiful thing jackie bradley jr
dropping down a bunch single and moving
vasquez into scoring position zuway lin
hitting 148 without a home run but he
does have a couple of ducks on the pond
here everybody knows if he does connect
he can hit it a ton
that's well struck on the move is
fischer that's over his head
into the triangle that skips up into the
stands that'll be an automatic double
and to score vasquez so vr is retired
that'll bring up lourdes gorilla jr be a
little patient trying to figure out what
you're dealing with well endeavors
couldn't get that one guriel hit it just
a little bit higher than t oscar did
and guriel will put the brakes on and
settle for a two out single runners on
it first and second travis shaw bats due
to pitch swing there's a shot to left
center field shallow lint coming on
still coming hard and he makes the catch
on the move they stranded there trying
to make a name for himself with the red
sox here
that's hammered for a base hit into
right field munoz after three hits in
game one he's aboard again in game two
the o2 from stripling and a curveball
grounded to the right side to les from
his knees they get the out at second
a big stretch by vr to force munoz you
see there's acknowledging the good
effort by vr
and rowdy
knocks this ball down and he still
senses that he has time to go to second
and they're able to get munoz and a good
effort by vr on the other end this ball
crosses the battered runner
as he goes to second nbr
holds up the baseball for the umpire and
his foot's still on the bag when he
caught it no question about it that's a
heck of a play vasquez on for the second
time red sox trying to do with two here
in the third
fastball rifled into the outfield for a
single
here's the throw coming home debors he
is in the score and the red sox take a
two to nothing lead chavis with the rbi
two outs the base is empty we're in the
fourth red sox leading two to nothing
one two pitch swung on and fouled into
the glove of reese maguire and it's
another strikeout for ross stripling
give him four
in his first four innings as a blue jay
as rowdy tales stands in to lead off the
bottom of the fourth now three and one
vasquez wants it down and in it's up and
away and it's swung on and hammered deep
left field turning at the wall is lynn
and
he plays it off the top of the wall
i thought that was gone and it was it
bounced in and out of the monster seats
rowdy teles goes deep it's his seventh
home run of the season
and the man who loves sitting at fenway
park just cut the red sox lead in half
first row of the monster seats down the
left field line teles makes it 2-1
boston that will load the bases for the
sox here and from michael chavis red sox
trying to take serious command to this
game
and strike one the throw is off into the
outfield on a misfire here comes munoz
he is in to score it just makes no sense
to me at all
maguire making a mistake and munoz
capitalizing on that red sox lead three
to one so first and second the tying run
is aboard right now now let's see how
liar
attacks the switch hitting jonathan
villar
and that'll get up the middle and
through for a base hit
richik will come in to score espinal
around a third we've got a one run game
on an rbi base hit
from jonathan vr
run at first base on an infield hit by
travis shaw and now vladi will come off
the bench and hit for reese maguire the
catcher
ground ball gobbled up by devers out
there onto first
got him for double play
red sox turned two so the red sox trying
to split this thing trying to make kevin
biggio the final hitter of the night
swung on and missed and that's how it
ends the red sox win it
they split the twin bill with toronto
3-2 the final score here tonight